وصلت البعثه التونسيه مساء الاثنين الى
الدوحه تحضيرا للمشاركه السادسه لتونس في
كاس العالم لكره القدم بعدما انهى نسور
قرطاج معسكر من تدريب في الدمام في
السعوديه وكان في استقبال البعثه في
العاصمه القطريه حشد من المشجعين
التونسيين الذين صاحبوا حافله اللاعبين
بالهتافات الى مقر اقامتهم ونشير الى ان
تشكيله تونس اصبحت معروفه منذ صباح
الاثنين عندما اعلن المدرب جلال القادري
القائمه النهائيه للمنتخب التونسي في
المونديال التي تضم 26 لاعبا وسيخود
النسور قرطاج اولى مبارياتهم في المجموعه
الرابعه ضد الدنمارك في 22 نوفمبر على
ستاد المدينه التعليميه ثم سيواجهون
استراليا في السادس والعشرين على استاد
الجنوب قبل مواجهه فرنسا في 30 من الشهر
الجاري على استاد المدينه التعليميه